would you attribute your success as a
streamer too
I mean many things I think being a very
strong trustler and having had a
following was incredibly important at
the start I think anybody whether it's
chess or whatever field if you have that
following to begin with from from your
career or whatever activity or video
game you do that's already a big step up
if you have that to begin with so that
definitely played a big role I think
more than that though for me it's about
the fans it's about hearing from people
how they feel I mean there are trolls
obviously but the positive messages you
hear when you hear about people who are
struggling struggling in life whether
it's say I've heard people talk about
having cancer you hear about someone
going through a divorce or they're just
trying to make it through day to day
when you hear about things like that I
think it really puts it all into
perspective about what it what it all
means at the end of the day and so for
me it really is the fans that they they
give me that motivation they are they
are the reason I do it and when I meet
when I meet some of these fans in person
like I have it a couple of couple of
events like just talking to them hearing
their story worry just just knowing that
I can bring them some Joy is uh again at
the end of the day it's why are you
doing it that's that's what it's about
if I can bring people Joy you know if
it's someone working working like in a
factory all day someone in the middle of
the country if I bring them Joy through
my chest that means a lot you know if
it's if it's a kid for example if I can
Inspire them to take up chess in a more
serious way or even honestly if they
just learn from chess certain skills
like critical thinking and that leads to
them becoming like a great scientist or
something down the road that is what I'm
what I'm ultimately hoping uh that's
that's what I hope will come out of it I
mean we'll give you strength to have to
turn on I mean I don't know how much you
stream but it's a lot so day after day
after day to be able to put that content
out there is there some
can you comment on the challenge of that
and maybe the low points how you're able
to overcome that I I actually don't fill
the lows and I think the main reason
that I don't fill lows is because at the
end of the day I've been very fortunate
even even as a chess player very very
fortunate travel the world meet people
I've lived a great life
so for me to see myself as a streamer
doing so well and bringing joy to people
I don't feel like I'm in a position
maybe this is wrong to say this because
mental health is very important but for
myself I feel like I'm very lucky I
don't really have any right to complain
so I don't really feel those lows in the
same but there are times when there are
certain things like Reddit or otherwise
it will will get on my nerves a little
bit but I'm able to realize that I'm so
fortunate and so I don't generally
struggle struggle with the lows that
much
speaking of Reddit and trolls Reddit
asked me to ask you to tell me the story
of Chess Bay the Reddit moderator who
pitted you against Eric Hansen
also known as chess bro I'm just saying
things I don't know I don't know much
about air cans I guess Eric is another
Grandmaster you guys had some uh drama
and tension between each other so we'll
also ask you to tell me what you like
best about Eric Hansen as a human being
here's what I was like the the whole
stream streamers and the whole boom of
Chess there are certain people certain
entities that are very very important to
what happened
um you know there are a lot of people in
the right place at the right time myself
botez the chess bras I love you as well
we were all kind of in the right place
at the right time but just having the
personalities alone is not enough you
need people who push things and
um there are a lot of things that have
been said about Chess Bay about what she
did at the end of the day the way that I
view it is pretty straightforward you
don't have to agree with what she did
manner in which she did things but it
pushed the game it pushed the directory
and chess on Twitch forward in a way
that would not have been possible with
anybody else at the time chess.com for
example they were not directly
um pushing it so you needed someone who
was pushing it and that so to me when I
look at the whole boom actually of what
happened on Twitch in many ways I think
she's just as responsible as I was Levy
was botes was in the bras were all of us
were extremely fortunate because if you
didn't have someone pushing it forward
until Stockholm was not really that
involved at the time it never would have
gotten to where it was so you can sort
of look at it and say okay you don't
agree with what happened but you needed
someone like that who was going to push
push really hard to get just to where it
is today
can you comment on what happened for
people who have no clue what you were
talking about is that not useful I I
don't think it's specifically useful to
get into it I think there are a lot of
layers
um people felt there were things like
abuses of power things of that nature
there were a lot of things that were
said
um you know I don't want to be super
negative about about what happened
specifically but one thing people will
note
um is that prior to what did happen in
April of 20 I think that was 2021 now uh
there were a lot more collaborations the
Chess World was much more together as a
whole a lot of streamers did things
together after what happened in April
there was a big sort of Separation a lot
of streamers went off in their own
directions because of what happened
um so that is I mean that's not the
whole story there's a lot more to it of
course but I think it's fair to say that
I if I can just comment on the few times
I've tuned into the streaming world I do
hate to see the the silos that were
created one of the reasons I've been a
fan and now a good friend of uh Joe
Rogan you call it collaborations because
basically everybody supporting each
other gets excited for each other
promotes each other and there's not that
competitive feeling with with streamers
sometimes I've just noticed that there's
a
natural siloing effect
I don't know why that is exactly
um maybe because drama is somehow
good for views and clicks and that kind
of stuff I don't know what that is but I
hate to see it because I love seeing
kind of
friendship and uh uh collaboration I
think this also goes like again try not
to be super negative but this also goes
to the chest world as a whole like one
of the things I've been in this trust
world for a very long time not talking
about online but just like the Chess
World itself and I've been very
fortunate because I've seen a couple
booms and busts like in the late it
actually wasn't late 90s it was in the
mid 90s there was a period of time when
Intel and IBM and all these tech
companies were very big on chess there
there were there's this PCA Grand Prix
World Championship held in New York
um there there also were I think there
was like the deep blue stuff later on in
the late 90s with Gary Gary Kasparov um
and you had a lot of interest at the
time and then it sort of went went up in
Flames for a couple different reasons
also in the late late 2000s or maybe
mid-2000s there was a group in Seattle
that was very big on chess they hosted
the US Championship all these different
things there have been a lot of booms uh
booms and busts of course if you go way
back there was the Fisher boom as well
um but inevitably what leads these bus
and the thing that leads to it is at the
end of the day people in the trust world
have this natural tendency to want to
not work together you want to hang on to
whatever whatever piece of the trust
world you have as opposed to thinking
about it from the standpoint of what's
good for one is good for all and so it's
one of those things that now that I'm in
this situation having seen these booms
of us I I remember when I was younger I
would very oftentimes think like why is
it the chest isn't bigger why do we
struggle so much to to grow the game and
I think you know we we see the reason so
now when I'm in this this position it's
also very tough because like I know
what's happened you try to learn from
the past
um but you still it still feels very
hard to uh break out from that it feels
very tough and it's also difficult
because another thing that people kind
of misunderstand is from time to time
I'll talk about myself I'll actually
talk about Levy and incomes or how well
we're doing and the main reason I talk
about this is that I wanted to inspire
like fide the governing bodies and
others feel like wow these people are
having such success like we we surely we
can do something different we can change
things and somehow it has not happened
which is in a way very very
disheartening to me because I want to
see more interest in chess you know you
want to see more sponsors more more the
general public getting excited by the
game so it is one of those things that's
very very difficult yeah so you want to
see Innovation on the parts of everybody
but also the organizations like vdhs.com
right right to uh how to inspire a large
number of people which is what this is
what streamers are doing they're
constantly innovating I guess of how how
to reach very large audience before we
forget just to put a little look you
want me to ask about error yeah yeah
yeah a little love out there what do you
like best about Eric Hansen as a human
being
um I think he's it's mainly he's just
he's very he's very charismatic he's
very charismatic he he knows the the
brand that he has and he's he doesn't
like he doesn't pretend to fake it like
he knows what his brand is and and he
owns it so he's uh just for people who
don't know and I don't know he's a
Grandmaster yeah he's a strong
Grandmaster but he's also like a Creator
yeah one of the one of the earliest
major chess content creators on Twitch
like educational stuff too uh a mix mix
of educational mix of high level
everything yeah okay awesome
uh what historical chess figure do you
think would have the best streams
historical chess figure I would say
probably Mikhail tal who's the former
world champion
um now he lived a he lived a very um
very exciting life let's put it at that
he was somebody who drank he's from uh
he's from Latvia he's gonna he's called
the uh the magician from Riga uh so he
drank a lot uh he smoked a lot a lot of
a lot of other stuff as well oh like
with sex drugs and rock and roll kind of
yeah he was he's I think if you look at
like actually not even just top Grand
Masters but like or not a moral chance
but top Grand Masters he probably had
the most uh most interesting Life by by
far by far
and even even like as an example of how
much he loved chess and how how what a
character he was I think when he was uh
dying in like 19 I think it was 1989 or
maybe it was 91 when he was dying he
actually left the hospital to go play a
blitz tournament in Moscow and he
actually beat Gary Kasparov in that
Blitz tournament in one of the games
well at what age uh probably like late
50s mid 50s like wow I mean he drank too
much so he died young but yeah like he
left he left the hospital in Moscow and
went to play a blitz term he beat
Kasparov well first of all just to push
back I think we all die too young and uh
some of the most impactful people uh
like uh Churchill did quite a bit of
drinking and smoking all that kind of
stuff so um you can still do brilliant
things even if you uh partake in the old
uh with skin drugs and rock and roll and
women okay
just about streaming though I there's
there's this quote that I mean it's that
I love which is the Steve Jobs quote
which is you can you can never connect
the dots um looking looking forward you
can only connect them looking backwards
and when I look at how I got into
streaming there were all these things
that happened along the way that were so
beneficial so one first thing would be
that when I was young I was I was
growing up I played a lot of Blitz chess
on the internet chess club it was one of
the predecessors to trust.com and there
there was no like No cameras or audio or
these things but one thing that people
did was you could commit you would write
comments about your games and things of
this nature and so I was actually doing
very I was doing something very similar
where instead of talking I was writing
and chatting during some of the games
that I was playing so that was something
that I was doing that was very very
beneficial without that I don't think
that I would have been able to have the
success that I've had streaming I think
would have taken much longer to get used
to it and feel comfortable with it but I
already had that built-in Advantage
um additionally when I was younger up
until I think I was a I was 10 or 11 I
don't remember exactly I did not
actually have a TV well I had a TV but I
didn't have cable so I did not watch TV
Growing Up So I listened to the radio a
lot I listened to a lot of baseball
games in New York Yankees specifically
um and so I think by listening to those
games like I I sort of I've heard a lot
of announcers and I think that's also
it's one of those things where you learn
from what you see kind of when you're
growing up um they're examples and so I
think that was very very beneficial and
then a third thing in terms of like
having some flares when when I was
growing up I was homeschooled probably
about 14 15. there were there was this
uh Great Courses I think they still they
still do some of these great Course and
there was this I don't remember who who
the guy was but he was a professor and
so I watched some of these DVDs of his
lectures and he would always dress up as
someone it was it was like Middle Ages
so he would dress up and he was sort of
like an orator and he would explain like
you know what happened in the 13 1400s
in this sort of style and that's also
something that obviously it's not
something that I can consciously like
internalize but I think it's something
as well that from having watched those
courses and seeing that style of oration
really helped me a lot as a streamer too
yeah the yeah all those little
experiences contributed to life that's
that's definitely something I think
about because I took a pretty non-linear
path to life and I think they
they somehow get integrated into the
picture but I do I do uh
connect to your um idea that you being
good at chess was a part was an
important part of your success extremely
I think like that's really good advice
for people to um
to be good like in order to be a Creator
or
a podcast or create videos all that kind
of stuff or stream I feel like it
enriches you if you if you pursue with
your whole heart something else outside
of that like you don't have to be
obviously at your level of Chess but
just you have to be developed in a
passion or procedure yeah you have to
know what that passion kind of what what
it is I think for sure I think if you're
all only doing streaming there's
something first of all I feel like
that's going to empty you over time for
some reason I've seen some of the lows
that people hit if they don't have this
other passion Pursuit outside of
streaming but also just make you a
better creator
uh which is interesting I think um I
think again with with podcasting this
applies like with Rogan I think he's
just would not the reason this podcast
is very good is because
all of his passion is put into being a
comedian and being uh uh a fight
commentator like the podcast is a is a
is a hot is a side hobby that's the way
I feel about it too that so that's your
main passion is outside of it I don't
know what that is
I think it puts everything in its proper
context and also it allows you to
mentally Escape into that place that you
find deeply
um fulfilling